the new Mean Girls film is not just a
remake of The Beloved 2004 movie of the
same name it's actually an adaptation of
the Broadway musical which was based on
the original film but some theatergoers
say they didn't know the film was a
musical because it wasn't made clear in
the trailers some shocked Mean Girls
viewers are going viral one video
originally posted to social media
platforms depicting an audience that
groaned and laughed when a character
burst into song has been viewed near
nearly 36 million times and another
theatergoer claimed some audience
members who disliked the music walked
out
early movie marketers have become
cautious about emphasizing the musical
aspect of these films and marketing
materials because some recent musicals
like Westside Story and in the heights
were box office flops Box Office Pro
chief analyst Shawn Robbins told The
Hollywood Reporter other films that
brought Broadway Productions to the
screen like deer Evan Hansen and cats
failed to recoup their investment at the
box office office the official trailer
for Mean Girls released by Paramount
Pictures in November doesn't contain any
of the film's original music and is
instead set to get him back by Olivia
Rodrigo though the final trailer did
contain a snippet of one original song
the film open to mostly positive reviews
it has a 71% score on Rotten Tomatoes
based on 110 reviews and the film
claimed the number one spot at the
domestic box office in its opening
weekend with a total gross of $33.2
million according to deadline Wonka
released in December also downplayed the
musical element of the film and
advertisements because quote test
audience focus groups generally hate
musicals deadline
reported still the film LED by Timothy
shalam has made a strong showing at the
box office with more than $470 million
in total worldwide growth so far
meanwhile The Color Purple has struggled
after notching a record $18 million
first day domestic growth on Christmas
Day
[Music]